[MUSIC PLAYING]
Loops are extremely powerful for repeating the same set of commands
over and over, but with different values.
A for loop starts with the word for, and an equation
that defines the loop variable, the thing that
is going to change its initial value each time you go through the loop.
In this case, the loop variable is iX.
The values that the loop variable will take in this case are 1, 3, and 2.
The loop variable will take on a different value
each time you go through the loop.
In this case, there are three values in the array,
so we will execute the loop three times.
The first time, we will go through the loop,
iX will have the value 1 because it&#39;s the first value
in the array in the loop declaration.
The first time we go through the loop, the for statement
is equivalent to typing iX equals 1.
The loop now executes every command until it gets the word &quot;end.&quot;
In this case, the only command is to say the value of the number.
One.
The code now returns to the for loop declaration.
Now, we are going through the loop a second time.
In this case, iX will be 3 because 3 is a second value in the array inner loop
declaration.
Now, the loop does its thing.
This process continues for each value in the loop declaration array.
Then we&#39;re done with the loop.
MATLAB continues with the code after the end statement.